[Applause]
the yellow masks are so cute like making
a horrible situation cheerful trying to
you've made it happy you're trying i
really love it
all right
i am
really obsessed with the themes of your
show good sam which is a relentless
force
that
you are dealing with all the time
yeah and i feel like that's a very
universal thing like everybody has
in your case it's your dad in the show
and everybody has this
figure person company whatever it is
breathing down their neck
forcing them to be better or challenging
them
and that's such a big part of the show
but it's about so many things tell us
about it
what i loved about the show
is that there there are these two
relentless forces and they they kind of
meet on either end of the seesaw
sam is a relentless optimist who
believes that people are good and that
people are worth saving and that people
are worth fighting for
and her dad is a relentless pain in the
butt
but he is
part of that older force that i think so
many of us so many women so many people
who aren't in sort of the most
privileged class are used to clashing
with and is this man to make room for
his daughter is she going to be allowed
to use her gifts is she going to be
allowed to step into a leadership
position and take up the space that she
deserves or is she constantly going to
have to fight because she's younger
because she's a woman because you know
she gets judged when she walks in a room
in a way that he doesn't
and you practice like you did you get to
see a human heart yeah like a real one
so i spent all my time prepping
shadowing surgeons in los angeles
and i was
able to scrub into these open heart
surgeries and be in the or for you know
six seven eight hours turns out i'm
completely not queasy win for me
a dream and i'm in there like how how do
you make the decision to harvest that
vein and how do you not go to the leg
because if i look under the rib cage
here what i see is and the doctors were
just like why do you know this
and
in one of them
i'm standing over this man who's had a
quadruple bypass and
the perfusionist fills his heart back up
with blood
i'm still gonna cry i'm sorry
and his heart starts beating and i'm
standing there looking at it and i'm
like
if people could see this i swear to you
we'd never fight another war
ever again
and every time i think about him i just
cry
it changed my life
switching gears a little bit
your podcast and we're actually going to
talk about it right now it's called a
work in progress and we call it the
download
this is so fun
so tell me about this podcast because
you've had amazing people on
you know
when you've when you're in the public
eye for so long it's weird everything
you've ever said exists somewhere and
for whatever reason in a in a chunk of
advice i was asked to give to my younger
self and to younger women
one sentence has been reshared and
pinterested and blogged more than
anything i've ever said you are allowed
to be both a masterpiece and a work in
progress i did read that i did read you
said that and
it feels nice right
and
it felt like an important reminder to
offer but it was also a reminder to me
yes set goals but enjoy where you are
and it was after the women's march i
texted gloria signed him to ask her a
question and i said something about it
to a friend of mine and she did your
podcast yes
she was my first guest and my friend was
like
does does the you who was like
organizing protest walkouts in eighth
grade and studying political science in
college are you dying that you can text
glorious dynam and i was like yeah
yeah
and then i thought
that's a privilege of my life and career
so what if i could open
conversations i have with her
conversations i have with other
incredibly inspiring leaders
and offer them to people
[Music]
you